اعربت وزيره خارجيه الامريكيه جاني عن
تفاؤلها بنتائج زيارتها للصين رغم
اعترافها باستمرار الخلافات معها بشان
قضايا عده كان هذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الاسس التي بنت
عليها وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تفاؤلها
بشان مستقبل العلاقه مع بيجين وما مفهوم
امن اوروبا الذي دعا الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
دعم التقارب مع الصين من اجله
ومستقبل العلاقات بين الصين والغرب في ضوء
كل تلك المعطيات
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان احد الاسباب الرئيسيه لهذه
الزياره لان اتعرف على اعضاء الوزاره
الجديده في الصين فاردت ان تشرح لهم ان
الولايات المتحده لا تبتعد عن الصين وانه
الولايات المتحده تود ان تكون هناك منافسه
صحيه بين مع الصين وانت كل علاقات قويه مع
الصيد هي تطور ايجابي بعد مرحله توتر
شهدتها منطقه بحر الصين وبعد اقامه امريكا
لتحالف جديد سياسي وعسكري مع استراليا ومع
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه هناك مهم ايضا هو
الحرب في اوكرانيا اذ ان امريكا واوروبا
تريد ان تثير تناقضات ربما بين بيكين
وموسكو هناك رغبه باظهار ان التمايز قائم
ويريد الغرب بشكل عام ان يسترضي الصين
ببعض الامور مقابل شروط معينه وكل هذا
بهدف ابعاد الصين عن روسيا ظلت تتمسك
بموقف انفتاح لتبادل والتعاون مع جانب
امريكي
فيعني طبعا هذه زياره يعني افضل من عدم
عدم زياره وكذلك هناك الحوار بناء وحوار
صريحا ومباشر مع الجنب امريكي
الصين يعني
التامل من الولايات المتحده تطبيق يعني
التوافقات التي تواصل اليها الرئيسين
البلدين
العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
حاليا المساله الامنيه طبعا مرتبطه بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ولا تريد اوروبا في
ظل هذه المرحله الخطيره بالنسبه اليها ان
يكون لها توترات مع عملاق اقتصادي ومع طرف
يستطيع ايضا ان يساهم بالتجسس بسبب
التكنولوجيا المتطوره التي يصدرها الى
اوروبا وبسبب الساحات التي للاوروبيين
مصالح فيها في الحقيقه الصين يعني ترحب
بالتواصل وتعاون مع جانب اوروبيسين ايضا
ترحب بزياره المماثل السياسي الخارجي
والامين للاتحاد الاوروبي وفي وقت التي
يناسب الجانبين الوصين لم يمنعه يعني اي
زياره نحن فعلا نعمل بتعاون وثيق مع
الاوروبيين فتاول مع اتحاد الاوروبي حول
مواضيع كثيره من ذلك قانون المكافحه
الجاسوسيه الجديد وايضا موقف الص حول
اوكرانيا نحن نؤكد اكثر على التنافس مع
الصين بينما اوروبا تركز اكثر على مجالات
التعاون مع الصين اعتقد ان المخاوف
الاوروبيه تختلف بعض الشيء هناك 20% من
واردات اوروبا تاتي من الصين مقابل تصدير
9% فقط من الصادرات تخشى اوروبا ان توترا
مع الصين يمكن ان يكون قريب حتى الى
اراضيها بسبب التنافس في اوروبا وفي منطقه
المتوسط اضافه طبعا الى المساله
الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
اظن ان هذه العلاقات ستبقى لفتره طويله
محل مراوحه بين
تمثينها اقتصاديه وايجاد اليات تعاون تعفي
العديد من الدول من منافسات ومن مخاوف ان
يبقى ميزان المدفوعات او ميزان التجاري
لصالح الصين سيكون هناك تعاون ومحاولات
لايجاد صياغ عبر منظمه التجاره العالميه
وغيرها من اسس التعاون المتبادل
لتخفيف الخلافات في هذا المجال فلما تعدت
مجالات للقلق والخشيه اول ان الصين قد
اصدرت
قراره او قانونا جديدا ضد التجسس والعلوم
العلاقات الخارجيه بعض المنع يحصل على بعض
رجال اعمال الامريكان الان سيطره على
الصادرات على بعض انواع المعادن الامريكيه
ليس هناك داعي لذلك لان كل هذه الاجراءات
هو من اجل التوصيل الانفتاح وكذلك يعطي
يعني
ضمانا قانونيا بانفتاح حسين